you know what Twilight is like Twilight
is like AIDS
it's that thing that's everywhere on TV
and then it goes away and you're like I
forgot about I don't even think about it
anymore and then something comes on TV
to remind you about it you're like oh
[ __ ] that's right that's that's still
around that's not over with now I got to
think about that that is Twilight so I
just randomly flipped on the MTV Movie
Awards and it was just like and the
award goes to the Twilight sucked well
don't need to watch that [ __ ] anymore so
then I go on YouTube and I'm like
alright I'm gonna find solace in the
videos online and what what the hell is
- oh my god a new trailer to the new one
there's no escaping it so now I'm going
to talk about the trailer so the trailer
starts out these people are getting
these letters and you don't know what
the letters are but about this time
right here when Teen Wolf freaks out and
goes for a run you realize ah [ __ ] their
wedding invitations which is really
pathetic for that guy cuz this is the
third move he's been to movies this is
the third word he hasn't gotten it
through his head she doesn't want him
she doesn't want you to just get over it
looked pathetic in like the last two
movies
yeah man cut your losses go after Blasi
or something no I'm gonna run in the red
turn into a dog in the ring because it
makes me feel good look at this chick
smug look ha ha Bella's getting married
when she's 18 she still doesn't know
what she wants in the world I was gonna
save all these Slams for the movie
review but just can't help myself
I what's up with this trailer music it's
way too epic for a wedding
are you serious with this [ __ ] I mean
this trailer music would work if like
magneto was pulling a submarine out of
the water or Thor was out there just
kicking ass I'll offended this
but a wedding it's just unnecessary
that's overkill just be realistic about
it and play Pachelbel's Canon in D major
I say play that because that's what
plays it every single wedding ever
you can probably bet the chips that
they're actually going to play
Pachelbel's Canon in D major in the
Twilight wedding saying great song I
love the song just ah Twilight [ __ ] and
then we see the scene like the only
scene I've ever heard about in the books
they bang and break the bed
alright I'm gonna be realistic to all
the 13 year olds out there breaking the
bed on your first time will not happen
and if that scene is three minutes long
that's 2 minutes 30 seconds longer than
it probably should be and then at the
end of the trailer Oh
oh my gosh she's pregnant that happens
when you have sex that's weird
oh there's another one another baby's
gonna have to chew out of her uterus
that's another thing I've heard about
baby chews through her uterus or
something like that
I got nothing I got nothing usually I
put the trailer below when I talk about
a trailer I'm gonna put it below but I'm
not gonna say you have to check it out
you have seen here what you need to see
about this trailer and to all the
Twihards who apparently are watching
this video here it is
you hate Twilight - just be honest with
yourself and here's why cuz you watched
me a guy you don't even know rip on
Twilight for an entire video which means
you wanted to watch me do that which
means you hate Twilight - now you should
subscribe cuz all the cool kids are
doing it so there it is guys the new
Twilight movie all [ __ ] part 1 got it
devices right we got a part to you to
put up with but think of it this way as
long as there is a Twilight infecting
movie theaters near you there'll be me
on YouTube to talk about it creating
balance in the worlds what I'm all about
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]